aber auf dem posten ich bin fast tot ich
fast tot alter
ich will was tot wir sind im krieg stand
road editor
es ist die zeit die zeit in der in
minecraft heroin statt blau ein neuer
könig gewählt wird herzlich willkommen
wiederum in einer wunderschönen
wahlspruch der maschine zerstört wir
sind alle anwesend also komplett statt
blau wirklich komplett ich möchte mal
kurz betonen dass wir alle angekommen
und dabei kommen nun immer lass es in
ruhe
ich schwöre ich töte dich ganz kurz die
ganz kurze zwischenfrage toski das mal
ganz kurz nur zwischen frage was ist
wenn manuel mich jetzt warum zieht und
alles mögliche darf ich den jetzt töten
ich kann mich hier nicht befreien war
nur dass es doch die junge ich werde
hier umgezogen mein verschiedene art und
weise zu wählen gab und zwar einmal die
art und weise dass man so wie ich den
zettel dem anhalt wählt in seine eigene
kiste tut aber andere haben so gemacht
dass sie es mit ein zettel mit ihrem
namen in die mittel mit denen gewählt
werden soll und deswegen machen wir das
ganze einfach oral egger endlich fertig
und wir können wieder kleine
begebenheiten und wird dann was sagen
möchtest du könig werden
unterschiedlich gewählt wurde und
deswegen machen wir das jetzt quasi
sowie in der ersten folge der selber zu
viel machen dass luca dafür zuständig
ist
damit bin ich auch einverstanden weil
wenn ich könig werden möchte dann tue
ich mich mit rewe zusammen weil ich
finde meine aufgabe gut
und dann möchte ich rede auch als mein
führer ansehen wie seine rede
revisor dafür dass wir autobahn bauen
damit wir schneller vorankommen zwischen
den einzelnen dabei sein und dann wenn
die wirtschaft ankurbeln hier
lernten lerncamps ich stelle mich
diesmal auch zur königswall und ich habe
mir tatsächlich zur abwechslung mit zum
letzten mal wieder einfach nur mies
grottig war habe ich mir ein paar
gedanken gemacht ich habe ein schönes
programm entwickelt das in drei tagen
haltet doch dass ich davon leben
und wenn ich könig werde werden wir auf
jeden fall etwas offensiver das wird
aber in gewissen phasen statt bin ich
meine ein krieg ist nicht einfach man
muss sich erstmal auf hat sich viel zu
viele gedanken gemacht dass viel zu viel
wieder kräfte platz gleich abgelehnt
ich bin ja ich wollte ich mich nicht so
war schnell wahl stellen aber ich bin
ich total überrascht begeistert von von
regis preis tage programm
deswegen möchte ich mich eigentlich
direkt anschließen und mit meiner
aufgabe dass er zufrieden und ich ließ
mich levi an als ein reh wie gewählt
wird dann habt ihr mich so zu zwei
prozent auch als könig aber sonst möchte
ich gerne nicht antreten
er muss mein schoko eigentlich hin leute
alter muss man schon wohin hat ihn
gesehen gesehen nicht mehr zur
wiederwahl bereit stehen
okay leute ganz kurz frage muss man show
cobo hat das ähnlich gesehen haben alter
wo ist das jetzt scheiße ist gestorben
zu gast in der bibel junge ist es
wirklich gestorben jetzt erst mal deine
features stehen bleiben soll
vorher versucht das alle gemeinsam in
diesem komponisten raum zu machen wie
mich die einfach zwei mal falsch gewählt
haben und schnell mithelfen meinen
chocobo zu suchen
ich weiß nicht äußert gibt sich eine
schokokuss so einfach mal beim alter
anfangen
ok sodann ist jetzt doch so nah
ich wähle den kev das sind zwei punkte
für käse luca jetzt noch ihr leben ganz
gut was undankbare aufgabe hatte dachte
ich komm du kannst dann steht noch
einmal oder ich steh ja gar nicht zur
wahl
der sommer hätte ich auch sogar gewählt
dann nehme ich einfach
du bist erst mal kurz gewählt wie die
nicht mach dich nicht dass man seinen
job vielleicht rufen kann oder nicht
die 2.0 das camp das geklaut hat oder so
ich wäre ja okay gut dann würde ich
sagen kann oder wer weiß
wir haben jetzt
und ein für mich nicht das heißt wie hat
gleich damit als königin oder krieg dem
krieg durch unter 100 jacke geklaut und
neue sachen okay dann müssen wir jetzt
ein kampf beiden machen
ich brauche ich ganz kurzen arena in
meinem neuen haushalt jedoch noch meine
erfahrene cloud ja ich habe da geb ich
hab mir grad mega abgeformt ja unnormal
ich habe jetzt gehe ich gern optimiert
noch oben standen also ich habe das so
perez aufgefahren ich habe hef dürfen
wir daran erinnern wir daran übrigens
erst einmal ganz kurz hier dadurch als
könig bist was ist denn mit meinem
rüstungen nicht stehen aber ich weiß
nicht das passt so perfekt und ich mache
ein schild vor ich bin nicht das machen
kannst du übrigens 3 np angeblich
brauchen essenz keeper führer kämpfte
gegen wien meidling habt ihr gleich
viele stimmen oder wir ja so ist das
eben
der könig eines wand hat ausgestatteten
in der stadt wohnen verbannt werden
sie haben neun minuten sollte ich auch
zuschauer wohl nicht entschädigung für
den tod die meisten shader aus alter
mitschüler mich diesen entscheidenden
zeit mischen ja so es kommt man rein in
den ring
ich habe hier angefangen zu ich hab mich
ein bisschen hingestellt haben
überzeugten alle bitte nach oben kommen
alle mit dem wohl des tieres treppen
mann du behindert
hier kämpft
halt halt einfach nicht weil ihren
geschlagen
ich bin gar nicht automatisch versucht
einfach nein ich hab was hier will die
stadt roth gerade einfach so gewährte
beginnen
da kann ich zwei mal wiederbelebt werden
belebt werden welches auf schild hat
darf sie nicht gegen drei tage programm
und zwar hab ich mir überlegt wir
sollten etwas offensiver werden wie
schon gesagt habe und das ganze gilt und
zwar als allererstes jedes jetzt
wirklich daran dass beide ehrlich
ich bin fast tot ich fast tot alter ich
bin was tun alter was sollen das mitten
in der stadt war der königs wahl der
lila sich zurück ich schaffe das alleine
ich bleibe noch alter klar dass sie
angreifen
wir sind im krieg stand rot und mit dem
tor
okay wir sind offiziell im krieg freunde
in der ersten phase sollte es so sein
dass jeder von uns eigentlich einer den
schein aus männer lieben stadt
kennenzulernen dass wir erstmal sehen
aha wir haben die schwächen zweite phase
ist die aufrüstung der stege läuft auf
mich zu und ist geeignet
aber das gibt sich jetzt ja nächster
termin wenn wir mal zusammen aufnehmen
gehen wir zudem und dann die in den
arsch alter ja man offiziell der krieger
begonnen hat begonnen
wir sehen uns dann in der nächsten folge
will ein geiler und dann werde ich
meinen plan in der nächsten folge
erzählen müssen genau wie man mehr zeit
haben also macht gut bis dann tschüss